hello everyone I finished reading the
Infinity Gauntlet comic and I have to
say it is quite excellent I did enjoy
the movies but there's just so many new
characters in the comics and it's also
very different and a lot more things is
going on I found I really found it very
enjoyable so if you're into that I
definitely do recommend it but now it
you know it seems that I have to read
much more as this is only a part of a
larger hole that I was only now
discovered another thing I wanted to
mention is devoting for the next series
there are already a lot of votes for the
next series if you are just hearing
about this at the first thing you will
see in the description below is a link
where you can go vote for my next big
series and the third thing I wanted to
address as my discord channel and now
one of the mods on my discord channel
accidentally erased almost a thousand
people so if you are amongst those 1,000
who got accidentally erased or you
weren't and you will just like to join
also bill beneath the link to the voting
will also be a link to my discord server
and you are also welcome to join that
now about this game it's a game played
in 2004 it's a correspondence game now
what's a correspondence game it's like a
normal game of chess but without any
time limit I mean there's a it's played
without a clock so one player makes a
move it's usually played between not
between players but mostly between chess
club's here it's played between ala
Chess Club
chess chess club obviously with chess
club and polish in a grandmaster a
rather sloppy Edenic as this game was
played in 2004 and yet did not receive
his Grandmaster title until 2006 so I
believe during this game he was still an
international master or maybe a feedom
master but definitely not a grandmaster
and what's interesting about a
correspondence game is that unlike a
regular chess game here you are allowed
to use opening books and chest databases
so although you can consult a database
or an orbiting book you are in no
possible way allowed to use an engine to
check your position so most of the times
Correspondence games will be of higher
quality
then regular games of course not always
it's like I mean the opening moves will
of course be excellent as you can use an
opening book and you can follow a
certain grandmasters game if you are
allowed to use the database about other
than that you are left to yourself to
decide where you won't go from there so
without further ado this game is like
the title suggests it's just the best so
I sure do hope you enjoy it
so let's check it out the chess club
opens with E 4 and it seems that rather
savvy dinner here is playing against an
entire Chess Club or perhaps against
only certain members of this chess table
I have no further information of this so
if you have any information of this do
share and I will add your information
you've shared in the description of the
video
so everyone else can enjoy or if you'll
just write it in the comment I can also
pin your comment but getting back to the
game we have e 6 the French defense d4
d5 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
vinegar variation we have E 5 the
advanced variation of the vinegar we
have a c5 a3 this is all very standard
and here most likely you if you play
against this variation or this variation
you're gonna face Bishop captures pawn
captures and then Black has a couple of
good options like 97 maybe Queen the c7
but here in this game after a 3 we
actually have a retreat of the Bishop of
Bishop 285 and here the Chess Club
proceed with Queen to g4 I also wanted
to point out here as it does include a
b4 move a very nice variation here is
actually before here you offer a black
to capture a pawn and if he does this
with the power for example CT after some
before then you have this very nice
Knights to b5 move we are threatening to
jump here with nice the d6 and it black
little replies with something like beef
we checked you can block with the c3
pawn and here a White has a very nice
position black has to figure out what to
do and the most uh most of the times the
black will just play push it back to c7
at the guard the d6 Square where you can
simply recaptured opponent you will have
a very nice game you can capture on c7
whenever you want
White is just ok here but ok I just
wanted to mention this as it features a
b4 move in the game Queen the g4 was
played
we have Knight to e7 and here we have D
captures on c5 so going away from the
center Queen captures on g7 is a
standard double pawn sacrifice by black
after rook attacks the Queen Queen
captures on h7 black will capture on d4
and here we will have a forcing
variation after b4 attacking the bishop
bishop to c7 and now Knight again goes
to the b5 and after a six Knight
captures Queen captures and black will
have a very nice game this is a very
nice Center if black will be able to
develop his pieces he should have a very
nice game so after Knight to e7 we have
D captures on c5 Bishop captures on c3
be captures on c3 now you can see that
White's
pawns are tripled here and black will
have a very easy task of attacking them
so Queen to a5 attacking both the c5 and
of course the more important one the c3
pawn here capturing and g7 is again too
slow if Queen captures then defending
with the bishop will result in Queen
capturing the rook would check and if
you just move the King then the rook
will attack the Queen after the Queen
moves you're gonna lose the rook black
will be up orokin of course having a one
game after Queen to a5 we have Bishop to
d2 guarding the the c3 pawn and now
comes the Knights to g6 nice to a3
defending d5 pawn and now Knight to d7
black also instead of capturing and see
what c5 wants simply to develop pieces
Bishop to d3 white is now ready to
castle and now comes Knight captures on
c5 will have castles by white and here
white can't black can capture on d3 but
if black captures white will undable to
move his pawn structure he will be able
to put d4 he will have a very nice
center so instead of like goes nice to
e4 he wants whites to get to give up
this Bishop for the night but without
fixing his pawn structure but also it
seems that after Bishop captures pawn
captures the Queen will also be able to
recapture the pawn so it seems that the
black is actually offering a knight and
the pawn here for the bishop which it
doesn't really make sense why would you
do that now the problem is white did
play Bishop captures on e4 and here
not immediately recapturing the bishop
but first the blacks idea was age five
and it does make sense
the knight is controlling f4 and h4 you
have you're kind of forcing the Queen to
go back and only then will you recapture
here and now blacks position is
definitely playable the problem is after
this h5 move white had another resource
that was not yet available to him when
this pawn was still on h7 here instead
of retreating with the Queen white as
this is a correspondence game had fairly
a lot of time to think about it played
the Queen captures on g6 so you already
capture one piece now we were capturing
a second piece basically you're giving
up your Queen for two pieces with F
captors and g6 and Bishop captures and G
sets this comes with check we have King
to d8 and now like we said you gave up
your queen for two pieces but you want
to keep keep the pressure if you allow
black to develop and to consolidate then
the two two pieces for the Queen will
simply not be enough so c4 first you
want to open up lines and create
possibilities of an attack against the
black King but also do it with tempo
here the black queen is under attack
the Queen has to move and then only will
you capture in the center Queen to a4
and now comes pawn captures on d5 he
captures on d5 you don't want to allow
White's to have this strong center so
after it captures on d5 now comes Bishop
to f7 white now wants to eliminate this
pawn and open up lines for attack
against the black King and it's not all
that easy to defend it if you try
something like Queen here then the
rocker can come to to e1 attack the
Queen after the Queen moves then this
point is marching forward it will be a
very easy game for for white from this
moment on
so after Bishop to f7 our black decided
to simply develop will have Bishop to g4
it would be very nice if you could open
up the white King's position as well
with Bishop captures on d5 now the
bishop is also protecting the knight on
f3
King to c7 and now comes Luke a2 b1 and
here again black has problems white is
threatening the capture here and there's
a really no good way to defend this yes
you could go Bishop back to c8 but then
your Bishop is back to c8 you just
played it to g4 and back
and there really is no good way to
develop your look here so after rook a
to be one what had to play b6 and here
white can actually capture on a8 but
look at this bishop it's a wonderful
Bishop in this rook isn't really doing
all that much so white plays a bunch of
better move we have looked at before I
would an attack on the Queen and now
there is a problem if you play Queen
captures on a3 then look the Seaforth
check will be deadly Ruby a king to b8
Bishop to b4 takes advantage of the
Queen's awkward position on a3 and now
you either have to give up the Queen or
move the Queen and suffer Bishop to d6
and this will be checkmate as the rook
is controlling the entire C file so
after rook to be four we have Queen to
d7 retreating with the Queen rook the c4
check again and here we have rook to b8
and now comes a rook to d4 again you
could capture here okay if King goes to
d8 then of course you can capture as
nothing is guarding the rook so the King
after this rook to c4 check the King had
to go to b8
but now white it doesn't want to capture
because this rook is doing absolutely
nothing and if you look at this Bishop
look at all the squares this Bishop is
controlling well obviously not the dark
square but obviously it's a much
stronger piece than the rook that's
doing nothing on a8 so instead of
capturing an 8 the first rope the d4 we
have Bishop two captures on f3 now you
can't capture with the bishop because
the rook on Defour is unprotected but G
captures on f3 we have grouped to d8 and
now not c3 if you please see three
blacks just gonna play this and say okay
what are you doing here I mean captures
captures and then it's a rook and rook
against the bishop and the rook black
has a better position most likely black
will be able to win this so instead you
have to protect the Bishop c4 we have
Queen to e7
now if the special moves Queen to g5
check will be an idea but also the Queen
doesn't want to allow this bishop to
come to g5 so white simply plays 8 4
also possible is e 6 to prepare this
Bishop to f4 check but then but I can
play h4 prevent a white from playing
gauge 4 and then
what the King will be able to escape
still it will be a better position for
white but white decided that there's
always time for e6 so first H for
preparing Bishop to g5 and now with this
the threat of Bishop to g5 what do you
play here as black there really isn't
all that much you can do if you try
something like King to c7 to try and
connect rooks and escape now white will
play e6 and now after whatever you play
there's really nothing to play and one
thing you don't want to do you don't
want to trade the look for a bishop
would route captures on d5 but you want
whites to capture here but you don't
want to capture here and create this
monster pawn chain now this is a threat
and there's really not all that much you
can do here if Queen moves Bishop to f4
check King moves now rook this rook
comes here and after this route comes
here this rook is coming to c7 and the
pawns that will simply be too strong so
after h4 Queen captures on a3 we have by
black and now comes the Bishop to g5
attacking the rook rook to e8 and now
comes look after d1 showing that the e5
pawn is of course not available for
capture if Lu captures and simply Bishop
to f4 pinning the rook if you defend it
nothing really happens here Bishop
captures on e8 Queen g6 check King moves
and now after captures and captures you
have two rooks and the bishop against
the Queen easily winning
so after look after d1 Queen to f8 was
played but now comes c6 and now there is
very little you can do Bishop to a
forest coming if I was played here
making room for the king and a7 but
after Bishop to e4 still not interested
in capturing the rookin e8 it was in
this position that Polish at that time
most likely international master or
rather sorry I did not resigned in the
game he resigned because well whatever
he does let's say you capture this pawn
your job is gonna face rook to da check
you lose the Queen and now it's uh it's
it's just a winning after the King knows
rook captures here I told over rook and
two bishops against the rook on the
other hand after Bishop to e4 you could
try rook to a7 getting this rock out of
the way but rook to d8 still wins and
you will either trade rook and lose the
Queen or you will play King to c7 and
now face this checkmate
and lastly but of course not leastly we
have king to a7 but now you're actually
facing a force checkmate so feel free to
actually pause the video and find the
winning idea here I will give you a
couple of seconds if you're interested
in trying it it's actually a very nice
idea for some reason I use actually a
lot in this video but try to do it for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations it's a wonderful forcing
idea and for those of you who are just
interested in enjoying the show
the move is rook to d7 check now King
Tubby it is a weaker defense so let's go
King to a6 now you have to force the
King back to b8
Bishop to b7 check King a 7 and now King
Bishop to c6 and now if you go with the
king to a6 then Bishop to b5 will be
checkmate so now you have to go to be it
with the king here we have King to b8
rook the b7 check King see it and now
this rook is coming to d7 and there is
no defense against rook to c7 checkmate
you can give up the Queen but this one
we prolonged prolong the game for a few
moves but yeah that's basically it after
Bishop to e4 around forgetting like
resigned to the game and this wonderful
wonderful game was created so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Konstantinos around the
duck is Captain Marvel Sitaram ready
Mohsen Yuna you're not poor in the mark
on the rad cry for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content I don't forget to vote for my
next series the link is in the
description below and also feel free to
join my discourse server I think all and
I will see you soon